this week on quad Riga on your marks who
wants the Olympic Games as cities around
the world prepared to apply to host the
summer olympic games in 2024 germany is
set to decide in march whether to bid
Berlin or Hamburg are potential
candidates other applicants include
Boston and Rome but not everyone
welcomes the Olympics while politicians
and business leaders talk of major
investment in infrastructure and housing
others say the games actually divert
public money away from where it's needed
there are concerns to that huge
international sporting events open the
way for corruption and political
propaganda especially if the hosts are
authoritarian regimes is the Olympic
flame too hot to handle or other games
still a force for good your host this
week Melinda crane hello and welcome to
quad Riga the countdowns on in just a
little more than two weeks the German
Olympics Confederation will decide
whether to put Hamburg or Berlin into
the running for the 20-24 world games
but opinions here are mixed is the
skepticism warranted has the Olympic
torch ceased to be a beacon and what
could make it burn brighter that's what
we want to talk about today on quadriga
with three people who've been following
Olympic Games for quite some time now
it's a pleasure to welcome yen's vine hi
he is one of Germany's leading sports
journalists and has won multiple awards
for his work as a reporter and a blogger
he has covered major sports events for
more than two decades including ten
olympic games and many soccer gymnastics
and swimming world championships and his
recently published an e-book on the
power struggles behind the Olympic
movement and a pleasure to have Erik
Kirschbaum with us he reports for the
Reuters news agency in Berlin he was
born in New York but has been working as
a journalist in Europe since 1989 he
attended the world cups in Germany and
in Brazil and covered the olympic games
in athens and beijing
and finally a warm welcome to Albert
steinberger he's a Brazilian video
journalist based here in Berlin he's
covered the World Cup championships in
Brazil for German TV and has followed
the events surrounding Brazil's hosting
of the world cup and the Olympic Games
from the moment the country entered its
first bid he also reported from the
Olympic Games 2012 in London inspire
like one of Germany's leading polling
organizations is now measuring support
in Hamburg and Berlin and it looks like
here in the capital city the support is
really hovering right around the fifty
percent mark why is that what is what
accounts for the ambivalence that is
typical for Berlin and some some people
who remember the the last olympic bit of
berlin for the olympic games 2000 they
also remember of all the scandals and
all the negative things were connected
with a bit and it's a mix of many of
many in of many things and of course one
important point is if you look back to
the Sochi Winter Olympics or two other
Olympics and other mega events all the
discussion about costs about billions of
dollars and all this is influential in
fact there is an initiative now here in
Berlin called that no limpiar initiative
Albert Steinberg and it says that Berlin
which is deeply in debt ought to be
spending its money on schools on
infrastructure on more apartments for
the underprivileged are you surprised
about this German reaction after all
this is a very rich country in
comparison to your own definitely
definitely but I think also it's more
than that imaginable when you look at
what was the world cup and with all the
protests I think there is a moment that
everybody's questioning if it's really
worthy it's stronger than ever this if
it's really worth it to host these games
and I'm i remember in 2006 we also have
like small demonstrations but now it's
the question that really divides the
city I mean as you said it's 5050 so the
size of it it's I think it's group it
grows stronger because of
it is exactly the protest in Brazil and
all these corruption scandals Eric
Hirshberg both cities Hamburg and Berlin
are trying to drum up support for the
Olympics not least because this polling
that is now going on will help determine
which city if either actually does
become the city that puts in a bid if
you were out there working with the
initiatives that are trying to get
support what would you be telling them I
know that you're a fan what would your
arguments be I need to think a little
big band the horizon they need to think
a little bit longer term what it could
mean for Berlin in the long term or
humburg Germans sometimes get caught up
in their own little world in their own
little small burger lakeer world and
they don't really think of the big
picture a lot of times I was really
surprised that Munich turned down the
chance does the Winter Olympics if few
years ago it just blows me away I mean
when you think about the world cup 2006
what that did for Germany's reputation
around the world it was an incredible
breath of fresh air and it was a
showcase for germany in the world got to
see a modern Germany they loved sport
that had a great organization had a
great even had great weather they
couldn't believe what great weather the
Germans had that summer and it's just
something that's going to carry Germany
in Germany's reputation around the world
for a long long time and the olympics in
berlin or hamburg would be another
chance and and the small-mindedness of a
few ignorant ignorant ideas in berlin
they think it's gonna cost money it's
not a zero-sum game it's not that
money's gonna be taken away from a
school or kindergarten and go to build a
new Olympic Stadium it's not the case at
all there's just a lot of misinformation
and ignorance out there and I think more
and more Berliners we get informed
they'd probably be a lot more excited
about the Olympic bid in Spanish Paul
mentions the huge euphoria that
surrounded the hosting of the world cup
what accounts for the difference why is
it that people are so much more
ambivalent about the Olympics and they
were about that and you can't it's very
difficult to compare the both events of
course in terms of money you can compare
in terms of the budgets you can compare
Olympics and in the world cup but in
terms of infrastructure in terms of
environment if you talk about the Munich
Olympics the winter olympic bid
the bid for 20 18 or 20 22 they are
totally different questions and another
point is it's quite it's simple to
organize a world cup in comparison to
the Olympics a world cup you have to
organize 64 games in four or five weeks
and if you look at the big leagues
whether it be in Germany or in England
or in other countries the big leagues
they organize such games almost every
two weeks such a number of games so
there's a big big difference between
both events but Berlin has these venues
already Berlin as an Olympic Stadium a
cycling rink a swimming arena the
Olympics is a two-week event in one city
how can that be harder than a world cup
which is spread out across the country
actually they don't have an
olympic-sized swimming arena that's one
fact and the discussion is is about it's
about other things and I don't agree
with you when you say if you if you are
arguing that the Olympics don't take
money away from other accounts they do
actually because most of the costs of
the Olympics are coming from public
sources and of course you could do some
other things with a money with billions
of euros steinberg Berlin's mayor claims
that the Olympics would generate 40,000
jobs here in the city does that sound
plausible to you on the basis also of
your experience in your own country
Brazil I think they are in the moment of
the bidding when they do the bid they
promised heaven but when it comes to
reality things look a little bit
different I mean if you take London 2012
for example they promised also to boom
for all the the industry and for all the
like hotels what they would really
really have an increase in their
business and you saw like hotel business
complaining and in a lot of situations
that it's completely different actually
so this moment of the bid you need to
really be skeptical about what
especially politicians are promising and
in Brazil the main thing that I have to
agree with you that at the end the
public money
comes to save the situation so for
example big just a smelly taxpayers
money because for example you should
have private investors and then at the
end you cannot find them and then the
state has to make sure that things are
going to go well so this is what's one
of the biggest problems in in the world
cup and I think it is now in Rio as well
that the government will have to give
like 700 million reals around 350
million dollars to exactly help on
energy and safety in Van Nuys apparently
Berlin's mayor did manage to drum up a
hundred thousand signatures from people
who support having the Olympics here
just to give a brief snapshot of how
divided the city is a local politician
went out last week trying to distribute
donuts with Olympic logos on them and
apparently was booed out of Kreutz bag
the district in the center of the city
but on the other hand the mayor's got a
hundred thousand signatures from people
who say they are for the Olympics so who
is in favor the organized sport actually
in Berlin you have six hundred nine
thousand or so people organized in sport
Federation's and sport clubs and the
100,000 signatures came from organized
sport organized sport is in favor and
actually if you look at at some events
of pro Olympics or no Olympia so they
are not so many people interested in
hundred thousand sounds a little bit
more than then you can see in in the
city and if you attend such meetings
Erik Kirschbaum people say support for
young athletes is lagging in Germany
that there's not enough there are not
enough young people entering a lot of
the Olympic disciplines would something
like this give a boost to that or could
one argue hey we need to take the money
that we would spend on the Olympics and
directly support education for young
people in sports I think an Olympic like
a World Cup is just a driving force for
so many things that would create jobs we
create all kinds of
enthusiasm for sports I'm sure a lot of
young people are getting enthusiastic
about sports again I think the Olympic
is having a problem around the world
right now keeping young people
interested the ratings are down in a lot
of countries they need to reform they've
had some problems the olympics were in a
lot of trouble in the 70s as well after
the montreal olympics which also lost a
lot of money there was a reform and then
things picked up again and and they are
having problems right now obviously with
the 2022 Olympic Winter Olympics while
the cities are bailing out on that it's
in a bit of a lull but I really disagree
with this idea it's a zero-sum game that
this euro going for a kindergarten will
be taken away from the kindergarten and
go to build some Olympic venue I don't
think that's the way it works I think an
Olympics adds growth adds all kinds of
things the world cup added about one
percentage point to the gdp in 2006
there's a lot of intangible things that
will happen when an Olympics comes to a
city and it creates a lot of jobs
there's no doubt about that but but I
think it the private investors have to
start to pay more bills and not only
taxpayers money I mean they need really
to they get a lot of increase in the
profits but they need also to share the
costs and I mean and I think with the
protests there they have been doing so
but just a tiny little stars at the end
when it comes to the real thing the
government have to save them when they
did you know I want to talk in just a
minute about lessons that we can learn
from games elsewhere but perhaps a one
brief word on Munich because both of you
mentioned the fact that the city of
Munich in a popular referendum actually
turn down the chance to bid for the 2022
Winter Games yen's vanish why was that
what were the arguments that prevailed
in Munich Eric's eric said he was
shocked but well what accounted for the
for the results of that it was a very
complicated internal sporting and
internal local politician fight so there
was a lot of dishonesty because in late
2013 when the decision was made in
November 2013 and shortly before few
weeks before there were elections in
Bavaria and in Germany and the very
elections in the IOC and the German a
German became the IOC president thomas
bach
and all these were very influential to
the decision because sport didn't fight
for the Munich Olympics they didn't do
enough and the politicians the local
politicians didn't do enough the concept
in comparison to other concepts was a
brilliant concept the concept in
comparison to if you look at the the
question of sustainability it was a in
comparison a brilliant concept
comparison to Sochi comparison to two
other bits and they they had a big
chance it was I say that it was a
historical chance for Germany for Munich
but they didn't use it because of
internal fights it could have been the
first Olympics in a winter olympics that
had been in a summer of venue could have
been history-making right there it would
have been a fantastic linking of the 36
winter games and garnish with Munich it
would have brought so many advantages
and I was a reason I was shocked is just
it was just a great chance for Germany
and if you live in Germany now you see
Germans are against the airport there
against the train station or stood guard
there against the Philharmonic in
hamburg at the moment it's really hard
for Germans to accept any kind of a big
project they just don't want to do it
they don't want it in my backyard they
don't want it there so will there be a
referendum in this case and could the
same thing happen here or in New York it
will be definitely because that is one
lesson out of the Munich even though out
of the Munich 2018 bit that took place a
referendum but just in one city and for
20 28 for 22 it took place in four
regions so and there will be a
referendum shortly before handbook or
Berlin will give their official
application to the IOC and in December
if you look around at Berlin and Humber
you see advertising for the Olympics
it's new for me I mean an Olympic bid
before was no brainer you didn't have to
advertise it but in Germany they're
actually advertising and trying to drum
up public support for it so I think
they're learning from the lessons from
the Munich debacle so let's see what
lessons we can learn from other
international games let's take a look at
some of the games of recent years and
the conflicts that surrounded them
preparations for the two
t16 Summer Olympics in Brazil are in
full swing venues are being tested the
security plan is in place Brazil has
learnt a lot from its experience hosting
the soccer world cup in 2014 but
problems remain for instance Rio is
struggling to deal with sewage in the
Bay where the sailing events will be
held few recent Olympic Games have
entirely escaped controversy the 2012
london games were seen as a financial
success but some questioned why a
festival of sports and fitness was
sponsored by companies such as
mcdonald's and coca-cola the Beijing
Games in 2008 saw allegations of human
rights violations and a crackdown on
promised media freedoms the 2014 winter
olympics in sochi russia prompted claims
President Putin was seeking to make
political use of sport and huge cost
overruns meant they were not just the
most expensive winter games ever but
probably the most controversial as well
albert there were big protests in your
country last year around the world cup
and there's been a lot of negative
reporting about readiness for the
Olympic Games but the IOC overseers have
just been due to Brazil and say things
are now looking good they're on track do
you think that's right or is it a bit of
whitewashing yeah i think the the for
the olympic venues everything is all
right they look at the stadiums and
other stuff they are in place but when
you see for example after the problem of
the Guanabara Bay that they were
planning to cut the pollution in eighty
percent and they already noticed that it
won't be possible and that's why the
sailors association had already went and
said that it's actually dangerous to get
a disease if you if you say on such
conditions and you also have the dozens
of other cases for example in the golf
course you have now the Occupy go of
course going on in in Brazil at the
moment because they are against it's the
golf course is made in a reserve and
where you have endangered species so you
have a lot of problems and the venues
get ready but the what remains for the
city so the infrastructure they may not
get ready on time that's what happened
in the world cup that you had like all
the stadiums ready but actually the
infrastructure that was linking one city
with another and the world cup in brazil
was really complicated because we don't
have a very good infrastructure among
the city so we have to do everything by
playing it was not ready they playing
the they blend a speed train between
some paulo and rio it was not ready it
won't be even ready for the Olympics
maybe so this is something that it's
problematic but i think the olympic
games in such sense brought political
will for real rio always i heard since
i'm i'm a boy in rio that about the
metro line tube stations that would
cross the road the whole city at the end
it was never ready and it's going to be
ready now for the olympic so it's it's
weird because sometimes it gives also
pressure that things have to be done and
in rio i think it will have a positive
impact although it
with there are lots of controversial
things evictions police pollution also
construction sites that has not the
they're not legal so they can I don't
know they have ambiental costs as well
so in this construction site so there is
a huge problem going on because thing
has to be done quickly Erik Kirschbaum
same story in Sochi as well with venues
and infrastructure that weren't ready on
time huge promises made cost overruns
corruption and so on can it be done a
different way or is this just inherent
in the whole process I see yenza nodding
but you tell us first of all I think
they're learning their lessons the IFC
is not stupid and they're they're scared
that all the cities for 20-22 except for
two jumped off and they're trying to
reform these things are trying to change
these things but as I mentioned the
olympics are a driving force for a lot
of positive things the pollution in the
bay that's an issue being tackled now
the public transportation in Brazil was
a problem but the World Cup worked out
fine I mean ever the world got to see
hey it works in Brazil anyhow they
managed to do it the world got to see
Germany is an incredibly fish in place
with fantastic transportation
infrastructure everything else and got
to see the Germans or friendly friendly
funny people the world got to see a new
Germany and I think the Olympics is an
incredible driving force for for
positive things and I think that's often
overlooked in this dollar and cents
calculation of whether an Olympics is
worth it or not so we have the two sides
there yen's of imma die on the one hand
the idea that a lot of promises are made
by the tallit politicians that in the
end aren't really fully kept on the
other hand perhaps a realist sing but
even less would have gotten done if we
didn't have the games where do you come
down you will be surprised i think a to
your question before i think yes it can
be done in a different way and that's my
big problem with a german bid for
instance because it's not transparent
enough you can create a totally new kind
of Olympic bit and the totally new kind
of Olympic organization but I don't see
it engine in
or Berlin what would my ignorance of
that they have you have to sorry you
have to start with referendums you have
to make sure you have to be transparent
you have to to talk about not only about
you have to not only to talk about the
good things so called good things not
only propaganda both sites and you have
to develop an idea behind how can you
how can you cope with the ioc agenda 20
20 yeah there are some some points in
the in Berlin and Hamburg bit but for me
it's it's it's not enough probably it
would be enough to to put it together to
bits hamburg in berlin that would be an
idea because it's possible now the IOC
has opened some windows and is in a
discussion around right now and that's
for instance that's totally new because
for the last two decades there were two
official rounds of Olympic bidding the
first application phase and after the
application phase they decide whether or
not to get in the final around finer
around this candidate phase now they
start with so-called invitation face a
discussion phase actually the the first
round the first talks take take place
next week in a nose on the trouble with
referendums in Berlin is that I don't
know people take part in them the last
two referendums Berlin had for the
temple off airport and the energy system
didn't even get twenty-five percent of
the vote there wasn't even a quorum for
it the idea is a great idea let's have a
referendum on everything but the trouble
is the people just won't take part or
they're not informed enough to know
what's going on if there had been a
referendum in Germany about the Euro
there would be no euro in Germany or
Europe right now referendums are a great
idea but in practice I'm not sure that
they would work in terms of cost control
Ian's family I saw on your blog an
absolutely astonishing number just in
terms of the cost of submitting a bid
can you remind us what that number was
I've been looking for it here in my
notes but in Berlin Hamburg they plan
with 50 million US or 50 million euros
actually I saw a Boston in the US for 24
I think the play
is 75 million u.s. dollars i think and
it's been said that Saatchi for instance
or cutter for the World Cup they have
paid probably 200 million or more it's
unbelievable Albert steinberger in terms
of these points about transparency and
getting people on board I mentioned the
big protests we saw in your country last
year around the world cup has Brazil
devised good ways of working with the
public or has it basically just gone
over people's heads I think Brazil is
the worst example on such matter because
actually Brazil we have after like our
democratic demonstrate democratic period
from 1989 we started to have more public
control among corruption that's why we
have so many corruption cases because
before they were not controlled and such
those organs they are not working
properly during the the two main events
World Cup and Olympic Games because
actually it has to be done quickly and
if you have to go through all the
licenses and everything else you won't
have the time to do it so they're simply
like skipping such such processes and
saying well let's do it anyway and
that's exactly the kind of lack of
transparency that's going on and you
have to have sustainable London I think
it's a quite a good first step for such
thing that they planned like after the
Olympics Olympics cannot be an end in
itself it has to be a process that leads
to somewhere else I mean Barcelona 19-2
it's one of the typical cases of success
that they always say because they were
aiming and being one of the cultural
capitals in Europe and they use the
games for that and I think you have to
in Rio it's just an end in itself we
have to make it and this is not the way
you should be done I got to smile even
because I think Brazil is even more
transparent in in one way then Germany
ever was in you can you can follow you
can download the newest information
about the budget the used information
the construction contracts and so on and
that is something totally new yes they
did it in Vancouver during the 2010-11
london as well that was perfect that was
really transparent at the end of the
face but and now they do it in Brazil
that for a German it's totally new
because our transparent the transparency
laws are so called a 19th century the
thing is like it happens in the
environment at the country I mean in in
Brazil all the costs are there to have a
control because corruption is so spread
that we need to have also cost so and
that's one of the things that I think in
Brazil works quite fine at the moment
that's why we have like so many cold
cases of corruption but but we also have
a couple the way of thinking and of
developing things in Brazil is corrupt
in its core so it needs to be changed
and that's in the sense i think it's not
David and I think Germans wouldn't need
such a close control in such matters
it's the mood in Brazil though before
the tournament last year was oh no it's
not going to happen protests once they
started the tournament the whole country
just lit up for it it was such a
fantastic atmosphere and out when
Germany knocked Brazil out I was waiting
there at the ferry and the brilliance
were cheering the German for playing
such a great soccer match it was the
most incredible thing i think i ever saw
was like this isn't it I mean in london
as well it was like this they were quite
doubtful and then started in london 2012
and also in but in German in 2006 they
were like I remember deputies saying
well I fear for foreigners that may that
go around Berlin because of noisy
situations or neo-nazi scene and
actually what you saw its which is
completely different so you always have
this feeling before a party that people
won't come or it will rain so it's I
think this is normally when it started
light up yes finally our report
mentioned the immense commercialization
that has come to surround the games and
although London in many ways is regarded
as a positive example in general
certainly the commercialization in
London was very extreme can anything be
done about
that is there a different way there I
wouldn't agree with with the observation
I think even at the Olympics yes you
have strong let's say ioc loss they have
to protect their top sponsors and they
have a strong law in father sponsorship
revenues but I mean in comparison to
other events let's see formula formula
one I mean that is it is not so strict
the Atlanta Atlanta games 96 were a bit
hijacked by coca-cola were a bit too
much commercialism and then there was a
reaction in Sydney four years later was
one of the best games ever because they
were able to take a lot of the
commercialism out so just because
there's one year one Olympics works a
bit too much there's they always seem to
correct themselves the Olympics so how's
that looking in Brazil is it something
that that people find disturbing or did
they take it in stride I think it's
normal that the main things that it was
quite complicated during the world cup
for example is that you bring rules of
your sponsors inside stadiums and one of
the biggest problems was for example
beer was not allowed inside a Brazilian
stadium for I think for five or ten
years because it leads to hooliganism in
Brazil and then because of the sponsor
they had to sell beer you haven't had
big hooligan his case in Brazil but I
mean this is a little bit uh it's a you
don't respect the laws of your country
and that's a bad example I would say but
i think this sponsoring it's a good way
to try to share the costs yinz varnish
cost control something that people in
Berlin and Hamburg are actually talking
about a lot Berlin says that it's
considering in its bid proposing that
the IOC members and overseers should
couch surf while they're here so sleep
in Airbnb apartments or you know on my
couch is this a realistic aspect and
something that really could help get
costs under control or is it sort of
window dressing it's a sort of
the racing but I'm not cool I'm not
criticizing it I mean I I like the idea
in general and i even i know some IOC
members who would definitely do that no
question at all but if you look at the
real costs it it doesn't matter are
there other innovative ideas out there
Erik Kirschbaum for how to do the
Olympics in a different more sustainable
more cost-conscious manner Lien's
mentioned earlier and I think the idea
is fantastic of Hamburg and Berlin doing
a joint bid and as he mentioned the iOS
realizing for our viewers just briefly
there only an hour and a half apart by
high-speed train 300 kilometers it so
it's definitely doable and the IOC is
opening the door now 44 Olympics taking
place in two cities or two countries
they want they want to reform their are
they're open to this idea so yeah I
think there's a lot of fantastic ideas
and if Hamburg and Berlin do it together
you can say you saw it on deutsche welle
first it's too late now I mean you you
of course you have to teach the ISO a
little bit you have to take the
arguments and then you say okay listen
we hear you and we propose something new
but they do it in the old way more or
less people often tend to lump FIFA and
the IOC together and say these are just
organizations devoted to patronage to
sudo corruption if not outright
corruption do you think that's right or
would you say the IOC truly is on a
different track now one cannot say the
IOC and FIFA for instance one big power
broker in the IOC within the IOC it's
actually a sheikh ahmed from kuwait and
he is he also plays a role in FIFA you
know I mean you have to look at at
people yes in I I know a lot of ioc
members they are 102 now I would say yes
honest people transparent policy of
those people FIFA is more difficult
FIFA's motive difficult the leadership
of FIFA 25 members in the executive
committee real still some corrupt people
in it fifa has
bigger problems right now Pabu
steinberger you've been in Germany for a
couple of years now would you say that
the political culture in Germany is such
that they would be able to get at some
of the corruption issues that you have
talked about in Brazil in a different
way is there greater transparency r
would you say or I believe so I believe
so i think it will be possible to do it
two things more efficiently and I mean
2006 was a great example of how they
build venues and they even I mean they
we did some sort on like lessons that
Germany could I could teach Brazil like
in such a matter of like the banner of
the the train station he in building for
example that was was supposed to be
ready only 2007 and they made it faster
so it could host the the world cup here
or such things that in Brazil will be
unthinkable unimaginable erik kirschbaum
whichever german city does put in a bid
if in fact either one does it's going to
be up against some fairly tough
competition apparently including my own
hometown Boston what would be the
characteristics here that might lead the
committee to decide in favor of a German
city if you were if you were supporting
one of those German bids what would you
be telling them I think in the current
mood having a lot of venues already in
place would be helpful we're not a lot
of building and a lot of cost has to go
into it the 51 billion dollars for Sochi
is is a headline that just is a
nightmare for a bigger that's like 10
times more than the Olympics cost before
that winter olympics so i think a city
like Berlin with its stadiums and its
infrastructure in his hotels in place
would have an advantage and a seed like
Hamburg as well Boston will have to dig
deep in his pocket to build a lot of
these venues so yeah I think geography
plays a big role as well the IFC tends
to want to spread it around and hasn't
been in Europe for a long time which
will be the case would be an advantage
to I States hasn't hosted a summer
olympics for a while either so that's an
argument for Boston's favor Germany of
course hosted some very
headline-making olympics in the past
nineteen seventy-two munich and 1936
right here in berlin now on the one hand
yen's van dyke we have an olympic
stadium in Berlin it's called the
olympic stadium that possibly could be
seen as a plus but are the 1936 olympics
sponsored of course by the Nazis is
there also a shadow that would taint a
german bid even now it's hard to say of
course some people will try to not
openly but they will try in secret in
secret talks they wait right to to to go
against the Berlin bit because of 36 but
I think I mean even at the at the world
cup in two thousand 06 the finer took
place in the night nazi olympics olympic
stadium i mean who was talking about it
and in fact Germany did renovate the
stadium already in conjunction I
personally I don't like I don't like the
stadium personally I would I would yes I
always think about the 36 if I see if I
see the stadium but I mean on the other
hand it would be nonsense it would be
absolutely nonsense to build a new
stadium no question don't know things I
like about living in Germany is over the
years is seeing Germany gradually
exercise a lot of its ghosts of its Nazi
past and whole generation i was born
after World War Two as we know about 10
years ago they put the right tet
reichstag wrapped by cristo and after
that the reichstag which is also a
symbol or not became just a whole new
building and i would think that the
olympics in berlin could be a way of
just exercising a lot of this past from
from the Nazi pass from Germany as well
I I hope Berlin gets the Olympics in my
lifetime I'd like to see that of a Sun
Dagger back in the early decades of the
games there actually were Olympic
disciplines and prizes apparently for
art and architecture interestingly
enough to of berlin city councilman have
just pointed that out and said maybe
this is something that could become a
unique selling point here in Berlin
where we have so many young artists such
a very lively scene of young people
entrepreneurs creative minds is that
something that you could imagine
possibly expand
ending the games or going back to those
early roots they would be interesting I
think one of the points is that the
Olympic Games have to change themselves
in the sense of get more people together
in the sense of that people feel part of
the game and the world cup for example
in 2016 the front fat was it they tried
a little bit too okay if you don't have
a ticket you can also take part of the
party and go to the Fun Fest and you
also have that in the Olympic Games but
this is just just little if you play
with really like the hope the whole I
don't know the face of the city and what
the city has to offer it will be an
interesting matter definitely I mean and
I think you need to think of such things
in spine life when you in your
experience you've been to more games
covered more games than any of us when
you look at all of that experience and
then here at your your hometown would
you want to see the games take place
here or not they got to organize it in
another way I don't see the idea now and
as long as I don't see it for instance I
think the idea of Boston some of the
offer what they offer the idea to
combine the many universities in Boston
and then use their venues and so on and
so on that's more sexy for me sounds
more much more sexy than the Berlin bit
so if you were redesigning the Berlin
bid what element would you change or add
to it to give it give it that kind of a
unique approach there are some nice
ideas and but I would open it up i would
say okay let's start with transparency
first transparency first let's discuss
and then we decide erik kirschbaum it's
pretty clear where you stand you want to
see the games come you'd like possibly
to see them spread out in between
Hamburg and Berlin other aspects that
you can imagine that would make 20 24
games in these German cities really
different from some of the negative
examples that we've seen I think I'll
we're talked about as well the arts
getting the the artists in Berlin
involved in Germany involved and and the
whole fan festivals of the world cup
just that whole kind of spirit where
even people without a ticket can take
part
and be involved in Germany they have
this fascination with the public viewing
which means something else in English
but these public festivals where people
can watch the events taking place inside
the stadium on a big giant screen
outside this I think Germany has shown
the world that a whole country a whole
city can get behind something like that
without having to pay a lot of money for
a ticket to actually be inside and
that's something I think Germany is
really really good at and can show the
world you don't have to pay a lot of
money to still be part of a big big
sporting event like that the way the
Germany's done it in the past in terms
of arts architecture and in history for
instance I think the most interesting
Olympic bid can come from Paris they
haven't decide now but I mean if they if
they use their city it can be can be
much more interesting and much that can
be magnificent much more interesting
than London for instance so what are
Germans don't want the Olympics your I'm
just so blown away by that idea you're
so good at organizing things you can
show the world what you can do why don't
you want the games you remember I told
you I mean I was more or less in favor
of the of the bit of Munich not in
general in favor of the Olympics but in
this special case I I was i looked at
the at the bit and of the on the idea
and I saw yet yes you can do it and it's
there is a kind of cost control there is
a kind of legacy absolutely with big
history and I was in favor of this more
or less and I don't see it in in the
bidding process in Berlin and don't see
it in Hamburg let me get Albert
steinberger to weigh in here before our
program comes to an end if you were out
there telling the IOC which way to go
would you be in favor of seeing the
games happen here or I believe so I
believe so i would like to see also the
games in berlin and take place and I
think Germans could give an example of
trying to make it more sustainability
sustainable and bring the sustainability
out of the games like creative ideas and
what would those be what would your
favorite favorite selling point B
for us a Hamburg Berlin I'm safer well
Belen I think you can really like try to
focus with the artist and what with the
vocation of the city and works more out
of that I mean and then try to get this
make it more like involve people more
and thats don't a billion has to has as
its core okay thank you very much to all
three of you will see what happens with
these bids in two weeks we'll know more
thanks very much for being with us today
and thanks to all of you out there for
joining us see you soon
you